the brain is basically designed to be
customized in the early part of life and
then to implement those algorithms and
that circuitry for the rest of its life
and so the brain can change in adulthood
and it can change provided that there's
an emphasis on some perceptual event so
in other words if you want to change
your brain as an adult let's say you
want to be less anxious you want to
learn a new language the key thing is to
bring Focus to some particular
perception of something that's happening
during the learning process and the
reason for that is that there's a
neurochemical system involving
acetylcholine and it comes from these
two little nuclei down in the base of
the brain called nucleus basalus all day
long you're doing things in a reflexive
way but when you do something and you
think about it very intensely
acetylcholine is released from basalis
at the precise neurons that were
involved in that behavior and it marks
those for change during sleep or during
deep rest later because most people
don't realize this but neuroplasticity
is triggered by intense Focus but
neuroplasticity occurs during deep sleep
and rest